I've worked the night shift many times
in my career so I'm excited to watch
this show you ready to rock let's roll
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
branch can't say got the branch you'll
bleed out that's good advice you never
want to take out any object that's
inserted into you or it gets impaled
into you taking out the branch is a bad
idea if someone's bleeding out
the first thing you want to do is apply
as much pressure as possible if that's
not working you have to create a
tourniquet an attorney can be made from
anything you can rip off a shirt sleeve
and wrap it around the area just
remember you have to go closer to the
body with the tourniquet from where the
wound is so for example if the wound is
right here you want to put the
tourniquet on here this renal artery's
cut i got a clamp it we're gonna use
this blood sound-alike go go go go maybe
this is something you learn when you're
learning about war trauma this is not
something I've ever been taught this
sounds ludicrous
it looks ludicrous it's giving me the
heebie-jeebies I hope I hope no one does
this as an EMT and crafts working see
Afghanistan he's a warg activate your
defibrillator with a magnet Jordan this
is migration you should have been the
one helping her if anything happens we
the only thing that's going to happen is
that you are going to stop being what
the horse is kicking you in the chest
okay it's perfectly safe I'm not a
hundred percent familiar with pacemakers
and defibrillators and how to turn them
off
there are reps on site within my
hospital that we do call if there's a
malfunction I've never had a
defibrillator that would shock a patient
repeatedly over and over again that's
never happened to me and I know about
the magnet trick it's kind of cool I
need to look into that further because I
guess this could happen to one of my
patients and if I have a magnet lying
around I should help them you got real
lucky taking that branch oh look at
nothing to do with it
ever dispatch I'll have a way to start
your shift we live in my first choice
she's TC do you look like crap
yeah victory other guys stomach testing
a little messy okay we don't just change
in the middle of the hospital and start
showing off well this guy showing off
his body
I love these dramatic shows and they
make it fun and interesting to watch but
okay not realistic I have to call that
out right away I'm done being nice about
this this is nice you know what I am
gonna ride you until I get that pig
you've got a boyfriend Jordan so sex
with me is I don't know if this is a
complete ripoff of Grey's Anatomy but he
really reminds you of Patrick Dempsey I
don't know if you guys agree but we met
last year at the Internet interviews
talked about the MCATs you've scored a
34 right 35 oh I got like a thirty five
point six good for you the way the MCAT
worked when I took it was it was a three
part test for example if you got tens on
one section 10 another section 1000
section you get a 30 I didn't know you
can get decimal points I guess that's
something new I wouldn't be doing that
new guy no worries man I know what I'm
doing all right and juggle anything you
would jump from the lost-and-found
yeah yeah that's not lost-and-found
those are things the docs are taking out
of people's rectums this month I want to
be seen now
all right this would not fly patients go
wild like this it happens especially
those under the influence of drugs
alcohol that sort of thing this is
heavily underreported health care worker
abuse whether that's nurses doctors pas
pharmacist whoever maybe get abused
often and it often meaning more than it
should and it doesn't raise any
headlines it doesn't raise any alarms
but it needs to we shouldn't have to
have patients yelling at us and punching
us and threatening us and throwing
things down because we're there to help
people
what does doctors doing is also uncool
stop choking people are you gonna hurt
someone for real you admitted her I told
him to transfer her back to Corpus I
determined that she wasn't stable enough
to travel she was fine she could have
gone is that your opinion
wait that's right you're not a doctor
tension between doctors and
administrators definitely exists I
wouldn't say it's this bad generally
though everyone has the patient's best
interests at heart not everyone is so
money hungry as they're making this
gentleman out to be
they definitely think about profits more
than they should but I don't think they
would ever put in jeopardy a child's
life especially a baby's life the
difficult part about being a hospital
administrator is that you are constantly
forced to make a decision let's say
keeping the baby will cost you so much
money these types of losses will become
larger and larger than the hospital be
forced to close down
you're hurting thousands of people if
not millions of people I don't know how
many people come to this hospital but
it's a tough decision
it's not an easy position to be in so I
don't envy that that job but like I
always say be human first hospital
administrator dr. whoever you are human
first break room
look at this agency this is awesome
tonight I want a break room like that
what's in one hospital we had a
ping-pong table and nobody wanted to
leave that room they have a
full-functioning bar and basketball hoop
that's amazing got a GSW drew you're off
the gunshot wound BP and heart rate
dropping all right what's happening in
here simple GSW I got the bullet but
he's still gonna check for fragments
fractus when you have a gunshot wound
taking out the bullet is not the most
important aspect of treating someone
because just taking out the bullet
doesn't stop the problem that's going on
with the patient and that's bleeding so
you need to control the bleeding and in
order to control the bleeding you need
to find the source of the bleeding so
pulling out the bullet is one step but
there's a lot of people that still have
bullets even in them because we stopped
the bleeding and there was no medical
need to take out the bullet we keep her
what do I tell the next 50 people who
come in here that we cannot afford to
treat oh you are an amazing doctor but
for some reason they thought that they
were better off without you during a war
what does that tell you damn care more
about politics and lives the problem
with being too ultra ultra istic and
there is such thing as being too
altruistic is you become an idealist and
at times as a doctor you can't become an
idealist you have to be rationally have
to be practical you have to be quick
thinking if you constantly put your
Hospital in the red because you either
over order tests or you perform
procedures that won't be covered by
insurance 'as you can bankrupt the
hospital system and force the hospital
system to close and then hurt so many
more people has it always been this size
or has it gotten bigger gotten bigger in
the last few years
I'm sorry to bother you with this it's
just party so much lately it's been hard
to work what if other doctor said I
don't have insurance
I work in Atlantic Health System
overlook Medical Center where we have a
fantastic charity care system that if
someone makes a small amount of money is
uninsured they can almost be seen for
free I mean some of the charges like to
see a doctor's like ten dollars or five
dollars they're very low if you ever
faced with this dilemma you don't have
insurance you think you should get
checked out or you want to get checked
out it doesn't mean because you don't
have insurance nobody's gonna take care
of you figure out a way to get seen talk
to social workers talk to government
employees there's usually a program that
we can tap to get you the help that you
need to see you drives me nuts but
there's no shock there you don't get
along it's complicated
sounds like an interesting story yeah
that's a long one romance drama incoming
if the patient can't pay then they get
the minimum treatment they just cost us
too much money well if all you care
about is money
I can save you a ton just shut down the
hospital and you won't have to treat
anybody well if we keep hemorrhaging
losses they will shut this place down oh
come on
I don't usually agree with
administrators but I agree here in
Afghanistan or in a war zone you have no
choice if you don't act this person dies
so even if you're not giving them the
best quality care you're doing the best
that you can in that moment to save
their life but in a time where you pull
up on the side of an accident
non-sterile the best thing that you can
do for the patient is get them to a
hospital as soon as possible not to
perform surgery in the woods
you see you know the stuff people say
food that's a fireable offense in any
hospital so I'm curious what's gonna
happen next because she went BAM kay
we'll take care of him so H outta here
I'll bet yes God is separated from the
spinal God I can see him moving
separately with his breath my God how is
he still life
I saw America Java really does live here
uhm saying that his skull is separated
from his spinal cord and then he sees it
moving with each breath I've never heard
this it sounds dramatic it is dramatic
could it happen yes the fact that he
diagnosed it so quickly in this type of
situation is impressive you gotta get
out of here in the next 10 minutes
a storm is moving in okay there wasn't
enough drama they got a storm coming and
maybe the car will light on fire and
maybe an active shooter situation will
start taking I feel like whatever can go
wrong is gonna go wrong in this
situation you can't fire him because
medically speaking he is irreplaceable
everybody can be replaced if you hit
anybody let alone a hospital
administrator you're fired you should be
fired that means you can't control
yourself and no self-control makes a bad
doctor I don't care how talented you are
come on let's do this before someone
walks in on us please
what are they doing okay clear all right
there we go trust me you don't want your
first time being on someone who really
needs it Paul you're up
we don't shock dead patients from
practice you did a spinal decapitation
surgery in a tent
I'm impressed yeah yes I am very I
really thought he was gonna make it I
don't know why I'm so frustrated with
this show he was a doctor in Afghanistan
that performed the neurosurgical
procedure slash surgeries and was bad at
them because he wasn't trained to do
them
it doesn't sound surprising to me I
don't follow the logic this show is not
for medical folks I know we're not
together anymore but it doesn't mean
that I've stopped caring about you she
loves him unbelievable
this guy's got a point three two alcohol
level creams another car and he only
ends up with a black eye and a boo-boo
neck get on the recovery 0.38 alcohol
level is very very very high just so
you're aware very very high I'm talking
about like a bottle and a half of vodka
high this button and your hand controls
the morphine from this machine that's
next to your bed it's to it's to help
ease your pain button morphine pain
that's not right people make mistakes
you have to treat everyone whether or
not their criminal not a criminal it's
not your job to figure out who's right
who's wrong a situation as a doctor you
take the Hippocratic oath for that exact
reason you will treat anybody regardless
of their race religion criminal status
not criminal status war criminal now
welcome everybody you can't be deciding
and playing God who you you are and you
aren't saving just take a nap okay you
need to be very still we only have one
shot at this when you take a nap I don't
know if it ever happens to you it
happens to me all the time
you get like little shivers when you're
falling asleep and that's really bad for
an MRI cuz you have to stay very still
so taking a nap is not always good
advice I love the army team
for anything
coming out it's not an option
that's okay your sexual preference
doesn't define you it doesn't define the
type of person you are your doctor your
job is to be a doctor all those things
don't matter if you like women if you
like men if you like heavier people if
you like skinnier people it doesn't
matter if you're good at your job and
you follow rules and you don't slap
people I love caring for my new boss
that Avenger eggs and the sex returns
fetus in fetu it's gonna sound freaky
you had a twin a twin yes at your
conception or or early on your twin
didn't develop but it stayed alive in a
in a very small tumor sized form inside
your body I could just imagine the pitch
meeting for this TV show it's like we
need a very rare condition for this
young girl to have where she has some
sort of other human being living inside
of her I've heard of stories like this
before but they were just a case study
which just means one person out of
millions that have this condition it's a
pretty rare condition where basically
the tumor is your twin that died but
didn't survive but still lives inside in
this little tumor all lives as a bad
term there's also tumors that exist
known as teratomas which basically arise
from the cells in your body which are
responsible for growing specific other
types of cells so within a teratoma it's
not unusual to find fingernails hair
really abnormal stuff and these
teratomas can form anywhere imagine
finding teeth in your arm that's what a
teratoma is like it's pretty crazy we
should have a conversation about what
happened earlier
[Music]
no reason this is a cool hospital where
people just slap and punch each other in
the face you're not really even cuz you
got knocked out from a slap and you
punched him and he'd left I had a
meeting with four Gosa he worked it out
I ain't going anywhere well that was not
a medically accurate show but it was
quite entertaining light-hearted fun and
I could see why a lot of people would
enjoy it so I appreciate you guys
sending me the recommendation I will
have to say there's not a lot for me to
comment medically on this episode
because the conditions that occurred
here were very dramatic and rare and did
the way that they perform some of these
things that's just not realistic and not
how most hospitals would handle things
and administrators would handle things
but you know it's a fun upbeat show and
it's like a hoorah army show and I dig
that I'm all about supporting the troops
if there's an episode that has more
medical stuff that you think is
questionable in its accuracy that you
want me to look into please leave it
down below in the comments because you
know I'm all about taking your
suggestions click that subscribe button
down below
and make sure the Bell notifications are
on that way when I upload a video every
Sunday 11 a.m. you'll get a notification
that the videos going live as always
stay happy and healthy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]